Hi, everyone. My name is Saad Ali.
I'm here at KubeCon, Barcelona,
and this morning I gave a keynote
about Kubernetes storage.
My talk was about debunking the myth
that Kubernetes storage is hard.
One of the biggest challenges
that we have with storage in general
is that, really, it is complicated.
But the beauty of Kubernetes
is that it introduces abstraction layers.
And when you have
these abstraction layers,
we can take a very big,
complicated problem
and break it into smaller pieces.
So, with Kubernetes storage,
what we're able to do
is treat storage
as four different problems.
One, you have to figure out
what storage you want to use.
Two, you have to figure out
how to deploy that storage.
Three, you have to figure out
how to integrate that deployed storage
with your Kubernetes cluster.
Four, you have to figure out
how your containerized workload
is going to consume the deployed storage.
So, to sum things up,
storage is complicated.
But the reality is that the way
we deal with complicated problems
is by breaking them into smaller pieces.
And what Kubernetes allows you to do
is finally treat storage
as smaller sub-problems
that you can handle independently.
And that simplifies the overall process
of deploying stateful
workloads on Kubernetes.
So, for the full talk, take a look
at the description below.
And stay tuned for more KubeCon content.
♪ (upbeat music) ♪